so the topic of this video are what are
called biogeochemical cycles and through
the video I'm eventually going to
discuss the water cycle the oxygen cycle
the carbon cycle the phosphorous cycle
and the nitrogen cycle but you know I
actually have a separate video for the
four I just highlighted water carbon
phosphorus and nitrogen I go a little
slower in those separate videos and into
a little more detail so you also have
the option to watch those videos instead
of the one long video that you see right
here well let's go ahead and get started
so the first biogeochemical cycle i want
to mention is the water cycle also known
as the hydrologic cycle and in the cycle
it's simply the movement of water
through the atmosphere now when you look
at a picture of the globe of the earth
you know about 75% of earth's surface is
covered with water
but there's a problem with that water
most of the water on Earth is
undrinkable it's either too salty
because it's ocean water or it's frozen
like in glaciers and icebergs so the
vast majority of earth's surface is
covered in water but it's not drinkable
water so we really need to understand
how the water cycle works so we can take
care of the water that we need to
survive so let's look at the stages of
the water cycle you know water rises
into the air in two ways one the most
obvious is evaporation heat from the Sun
causes water vapor to rise into the air
so liquid from the pond liquid water
turns into a vapor and rises into the
air a second way that water rises into
the air is through what's called
transpiration plants will lose water
through their leaves
that's what transpiration so when we
look at transpiration in a little more
detail plants have these tiny openings
called stomata on their leaves here's a
leaf let's zoom on in and when we do we
see it almost looks like an eyeball were
zoomed in here really really high highly
magnified this is an example of a
stomata here it's a tiny pore
microscopic where water vapor can exit
so this is how water exits
during transpiration so when we look at
our cycle again water is rising through
evaporation and transpiration well what
happens is of course water collects in
the atmosphere and eventually it's going
to condense and form clouds and so when
we continue on with our hydrologic cycle
now that there's water vapor in the
atmosphere condensation occurs because
as water rises into the air it
eventually encounters cooler
temperatures you know you know examples
of condensation on a hot summer day for
instance let's say you take a soda out
of the refrigerator and leave it outside
for five minutes after five minutes you
come back and there's these little water
droplets all over all over the the soda
bottle well did water leak out of the
bottle no moisture in the air water
moisture in the air came in contact with
a cold bottle and it condensed and form
these little droplets so the same thing
happens is when water vapor rises into
the air it cools and condenses and forms
clouds clouds of the effects the results
of condensation and then once clouds are
formed that will lead to some form of
precipitation the falling of water back
to the surface of the earth and when it
comes to precipitation they might be the
most obvious type of such as
precipitation of rain or of course
there's the precipitation called snow
precipitation called sleet it's kind of
like it's not cold enough for snow not
warm enough for rain you get this
mixture of slushy material called sleet
by the way sleet is really slippery to
driver drive on for all you young
drivers so if you ever caught in a sleet
storm pull over get some lunch and wait
the storm out and then there's hail hail
is the fourth type of precipitation
little chunks of ice can fall to the
ground and when you look at this persons
holding hail balls in their hand you can
imagine these things are falling from
very high altitudes and they could cause
bodily injury or even property
damage you see here is a broken window
the back window of this automobile has
been broken out because of hail damage
so if you live in areas that constantly
get hail you may want to look into hail
insurance and so on once water is on the
ground because of precipitation to one
of two things will happen either it will
run off downhill and runoff is simply
when water runs downhill into a river
into a lake into an ocean or the water
will soak into the soil and that we call
that infiltration and when water soaks
into the soil it begins to collect
underground in the this big pool of
water underground called groundwater and
that's where a lot of the world gets its
drinking supply from drinking water from
is from underground groundwater and so
when we look at this picture here we can
see that there's you know a cutaway of
the earth we can see the groundwater
underneath the surface well what we'll
do is we'll drill wells down into that
groundwater and then we can pump the
water out of the ground and use it for
our everyday needs
so how come how come these underground
supplies of water don't go empty
well that's because of infiltration the
groundwater is recharged or resupplied
or restocked because of infiltration if
water didn't seep back into the ground
water would run out so the purpose of
this final slide on the water cycle is
to show just a summary of the two ways
that water goes up transpiration and
evaporation eventually that leads to
clouds condensing and forming and when
water vapor gets too heavy it condenses
and then it falls as some type of
precipitation when water hits the ground
it will either then run off downhill or
it will soak into the soil as
infiltration either way I hope you see
we have a nice cycle and again this is
simply the hydrologic or the water cycle
so as we now switch to the oxygen cycle
this I don't have a specific video for
the oxygen cycle because this is pretty
quick and pretty basic but the tree
represents photosynthetic autotrophs and
photosynthesis requires
the intake of carbon dioxide again
plants have those stomata which I
mentioned it during the water cycle and
when the stomata are open they can take
in carbon dioxide simply from the
environment from the air and they will
use that carbon dioxide to produce their
food in the process of photosynthesis
and as a result of producing their food
through photosynthesis they will release
oxygen as a waste the oxygen simply
exits through the stomata when they're
open and accumulates in the atmosphere
and then come the heterotrophs
represented by our cow now again
heterotrophs can be not just animals but
let's also let's not also forget you
know fungus and decomposers and bacteria
and so through the process of cellular
respiration
oxygen will be inhaled oxygen will be
inhaled the oxygen that came from
photosynthetic organisms is inhaled and
cellular respiration if you recalls the
process that were ATP adenosine
triphosphate is made and in order to
make ATP oxygen is one of the reactants
and so the the cow is now exhaling
carbon dioxide because carbon dioxide is
a waste product of cellular respiration
and so you can see from the video here
we have a nice a pretty straightforward
overall cycle where the cow gives off
carbon dioxide which is taken in by the
plant the plant gives off oxygen which
is taken in by the cow so when we look
at the carbon cycle I want to look at
the carbon cycle next carbon why do we
need it because carbon is the basis of
organic molecules remember the four
categories of organic molecules you got
proteins remember proteins are a big
chain of amino acids foods that are high
in proteins would be like fish and eggs
and and steak and meat and let's not
forget another category are
carbohydrates the diagram is a diagram
of glucose you can see carbon in the
diagram of glucose foods that are high
in carbohydrates would be pastas and
fruits a third category of organic
molecules would be lipids here we have a
and an
nation of the cell membrane the
phospholipid bilayer and so the outer
boundary of every cell in our body needs
carbon and then the fourth category of
organic molecule the nucleic acids the
DNA and the RNA the genetic basis of
life here on earth so that makes carbon
really important let's go ahead and go
on into the stages now so when we focus
on the carbon cycle you know plants and
producers so you see the plant on the
far right is absorbing carbon dioxide so
it can use carbon dioxide as one of the
reactants of photosynthesis and through
photosynthesis this plant and other
types of autotrophs will produce glucose
remember glucose is carbon-based so
there's carbon in glucose and then now
that the plant has made carbon the
carbon simply moves up the food chain
the plants has made carbon in the form
of glucose and the glucose simply moves
up the food chain the in the animation
glucose is going to the rabbit because
the rabbits eating the plant glucose is
going to the wolf because the wolf is
eating the rabbit glucose simply moves
up the food chain animals let's not
forget do cellular respiration and as a
result they release carbon dioxide back
into the environment so if you notice in
the animation we already have a little
cycle and we're not entirely done yet
though so before we finish this up I
want to mention of course the role of
the decomposers they're gonna obtain
glucose by feeding on the dead so in the
animation glucose from a dead wolf from
a dead rabbit from dead plants are going
to the mushrooms which represent
decomposers and decomposers also do
cellular respiration so they to release
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere so
now we have a full cycle involving
autotrophs heterotrophs and decomposers
and so before we move on I want to
mention the human contribution you know
excess amount of carbon dioxide has been
released and burned I should say excess
amount of carbon dioxide
been released into the atmosphere from
the burning of fossil fuels like coal
oil and natural gas so in the animation
you see a factory release and all these
extra amounts of carbon dioxide this is
leading our carbon cycle to be out of
balance and so you know later on we're
gonna go over some of the the details of
climate change and global warming and
but for for those you who understand
this topic it's because of carbon
dioxide and other greenhouse gases like
methane are out of balance with the
natural carbon cycle so with our cycle
being out of balance you know we're
fearful that this could alter you know
weather patterns around the world and
and and disrupt some of the cycles the
natural weather cycles that we've seen
for thousands of years so the purpose of
this slide is just to show a summary of
the cycle and I hope you can see a
clockwise cycle in my animation here and
so you can see carbon cycling and moving
in a circular motion throughout the
environment let's go ahead and go into
the next cycle okay so the next cycle I
want to mention is called the
phosphorous cycle and you know there's a
problem we need phosphorus but there's
no phosphorus in the atmosphere and the
reason we need phosphorus is because
phosphorus is needed to make ATP here's
a mitochondria picture and if we look at
the molecule ATP you can see there's P
in it for phosphorus we also need
phosphorus to make DNA deoxyribonucleic
acid if we look at a nucleotide we can
see that there's a P in the diagram
because again one of the parts of a
nucleotide is called a phosphate group
and when you combine one nucleotide with
several others you have a molecule
called DNA and another reason why we
need phosphorus is because of lipids
here's a picture of a cell membrane
remember that a cell membrane is made
from a phospholipid bilayer phospho
phospholipid because it was phosphorus
in it so let's go ahead and get into the
steps of the phosphorous cycle so when
we look at the stages of the phosphorous
cycle we see
it's raining in my animation and that's
kind of one of the most important steps
this helps release phosphorus from rocks
there is no phosphorous in the
atmosphere but there's phosphorus in
rocks and when rocks are exposed to rain
and and changing temperatures and the
cold and thawing
this helps to release phosphorus from
the rocks and now that there's
phosphorous in the soil it simply is
taken up through the roots of of plants
and producers and now that it's in
producers it simply moves up the food
chain and once phosphorus is orbed
absorbed through the roots of plants
phosphorus simply moves up the food
chain from the plants to the snail
because snails eat plants from the snail
to the Frog because frogs eat snails
phosphorus is moving up the food chain
and even to the decomposers decomposers
obtain their phosphorus because they
consume dead plants and dead snails and
dead frogs and so decomposers like
mushrooms obtain phosphorous by feeding
on the dead and then decomposers kind of
complete our cycle because they release
phosphorous in their waste and so once
phosphorous is and is back into the soil
plants can take it in through their
roots and so when before we wrap up the
phosphorous cycle I want to mention the
human contribution to either humans
we're using fertilizers which contain
phosphorus were adding fertilizers
because that helps our crops grow better
here's a picture of a farmer pulling a
tractor spraying
fertilizers onto his crops it's gonna
help the crops grow better so the
problem is that when when phosphorus
fertilizers are used for instance in
this animation we're going to show often
the phosphorus will be added to the
crops or the plants or even to a garden
at home and then the phosphorus simply
runs off with rain here's a picture of
some water running off of a farm and
just taking away the phosphorus
fertilizers
we added to help the crop and so here's
a little animation of a farmer
spraying their crops with a bunch of
phosphorus because again it's one of the
ingredients of fertilizers and so now
that phosphorus has been added to the
crops
the problem is now that phosphorus has
been added to the crops next time it
rains the rain water will simply carry
the phosphorus downhill and eventually
accumulates in this little pond that you
see in my animation
well this often leads to an explosion of
algae this is causes what are called
algal blooms remember phosphorous is a
fertilizer
it helps plant and plant like organisms
grow and so the algae responds to the
extra amounts of phosphorous by growing
causes what I called algal blooms here's
a picture from overhead of an algal
bloom you can see the green layer of
algae in this little watery environment
here and again another picture you can
see how green the water looks so why is
this bad well this leads to a problem
called eutrophication and this actually
causes a dead zone so this water which
is now full of algae ironically life
begins to suffocate you would think why
is it suffocating aren't the algae
photosynthetic and putting oxygen into
the water
well that's true at first but over time
this causes a growth of bacteria and
over time when the bacteria die in decay
that decaying process removes a lot of
the oxygen from the water so organisms
like fish literally suffocate and die it
causes a dead zone that's the process
called eutrophication so sadly again
because of human contributions the
phosphorous cycle is out of balance and
we hope that we can be responsible with
how we use fertilizers and so perhaps
look for natural fertilizers instead of
store-bought fertilizers and you know
you can also support organic farming in
farmers markets because these are foods
that are typically grown without
fertilizers and also pesticides moving
on to the next cycle so the final cycle
I want to mention is called the nitrogen
cycle well you know there's a problem
when it comes to our ability to use
night
most of the nitrogen that's in the
atmosphere by the way 78% of our
atmosphere is end to nitrogen gas the
problem is it's not usable and here's a
reason why the molecule n2 the nitrogen
that's in the atmosphere it's held
together by a very stable triple bond
and because it's held together by a very
stable triple bond our cells really
aren't able to convert it and break it
down so there's a problem we have to get
nitrogen but the nitrogen in the air is
not usable so we'll go over where the
nitrogen then comes from well why do we
need nitrogen in the first place well we
mentioned DNA earlier in some of the
other cycles but nitrogen is one of the
building blocks of DNA we look at this
picture of a nucleotide that we saw
earlier and again DNA is made up of four
nitrogen bases atcg adenine thymine
cytosine guanine they all have nitrogen
in them so the fact that DNA is is made
from nitrogen that's pretty good reason
why we need it let's go ahead and get
into the cycle so when we look at the
nitrogen cycle again the problem we
mentioned is is that the nitrogen in the
atmosphere is not usable but there are
bacteria in the soil and in the
animation you can see n2 is coming from
the atmosphere into those bacteria and
the bacteria are releasing a form of
waste called nitrates this is a more
usable form of nitrogen so this
conversion process where bacteria
convert atmospheric nitrogen into
nitrates is known as nitrogen fixation
so this is really the first key step in
the nitrogen cycle in area 2 of the
picture there are other bacteria that
will use those nitrates they'll take in
the nitrates and they'll give off and to
back into the air and you notice we've
already got ourselves a little bit of a
cycle here and we're only looking we've
only so far looked at the bacteria but
let's move on into the producers in area
3 we have our plant so the producer the
plant in this picture has roots and the
roots of course go deep into the soil
and the roots will absorb in this
KACE nitrates the nitrates that were
made by bacteria in area one the
nitrates that were made through nitrogen
fixation are taken up through the roots
and once the nitrates the nitrogen is in
the roots of a plant the nitrogen simply
moves up the food chain in area four we
have our rodents our squirrel and simply
nitrogen is moving up the food chain
you know the squirrels eating the plant
may be a snake eats the squirrel maybe
an owl or a hawk eats the snake and so
nitrogen simply moves up the food chain
and then you notice area five we have a
mushroom symbolic of our decomposers
well they feed on dead organisms so
there's nitrogen going from the squirrel
let's say the squirrel dies and it's
dead remains are fed on by the the
mushroom the decomposes notice that
there's also nitrogen coming out of
there's nitrogen coming out of the
mushroom there's nitrates coming out of
the mushroom because that's one of their
waste products so they too will I will
add nitrates back into the soil the
nitrates can then be retaken up by
plants and so notice how we have a nice
little cycle here this is known as the
nitrogen cycle I wanted to quickly
mention the role that lightning plays in
the nitrogen cycle energy from lightning
is gonna break apart the n2 and break
apart the o2 so watching my animation
here's some n2 and some oxygen that's in
the atmosphere and when it when
lightning strikes energy will break
apart those n twos and those Oh 2 's
into single ends and single O's single
nitrogen's and single oxygens when that
happens molecule called nitrogen oxide
will form and so nitrogen oxide you can
see is just form and o2 is nitrogen
oxide it's just formed and nitrogen
oxides are gonna react with rainwater
because you know with lightning usually
comes rain and so when it rains those
nitrogen oxide
aides are gonna react with rainwater to
form
no.3 nitrates and the nitrates simply
fall down to thou in the rain to the
ground and once the nitrates are in the
soil they can be absorbed through the
roots of plants like we saw a few
moments ago so I just wanted to quickly
mention the role that lightning plays in
the nitrogen cycle so there you go
there's five biogeochemical cycles you
know if you think I went a little quick
in either the water cycle the carbon
cycle the nitrogen cycle or the
phosphorous cycle I have a specific
video for each of those four you may
want to try watching those because I do
go a little slower and take my time a
little more in those specific videos so
if you're in my class pause the video
perhaps try to answer these questions on
a separate sheet of paper I'd be happy
to check your answers either before
school or after school good luck